[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys I figured I'd pop
over here uh dirt's not here yet
I just sent him the link like five ten
minutes ago I went and got some some
Subway
that's what was taking so long you're
getting some Subway
so I can understand if I hit him
randomly
usually I give people the links
I would say
an hour well about 30 minutes before
most the time sometimes I'll pop in
there and uh be a bad host and give us
less
you see Cog be given the link like a day
before to our guests
see cog's the professional one
see I TR I my goal
is to do it with the least amount of
work but still works
that's what my goal is
and most the time I I succeed
and then sometimes I don't
so what's what's going on guys
oh I got a um
got a hot ham and cheese
you know I'm a basic dude
doesn't take much to keep me happy
as long as I eat I eat
hold up guys dirt's here give me one
second
they can't hear you dirt not yet
I don't I don't do hot mics to the uh
to the to the
to the panel like that I feel like it's
rude
let me turn off the camera
and we turn on this camera
okay let me delete the camera sometimes
Zoom be like real weird they'll be like
you know
we might work we don't know
all right what about now there we go
it's working it's working
I'm sure you did
um did you ever play the old uh N64
um
Star Wars game like Star Wars uh what is
it called Star Wars
no I never played a hard racing one the
pod racing oh no no I never played let
me figure out what that's called I'm
sure someone's gonna beat them to me
N64
I gotta hurry up before the chat answers
it
pod racing
is I know it's all called racer all
right Chad go ahead and answer it
couldn't do it before you guys do it
I'm sure you guys have uh all types of
things you're going you know we got a
pretty pretty yeah start no I don't
think it was called racer
It's like Star Wars like
it might have been called racer I feel
like it was something racer
I feel like it was something racer like
it might have been called racer
it might have been called racer because
I remember there was like is it the one
where like Anakin always like says it's
working it's working it's working like
because I I remember playing that so
much
and that that that's my whole point of
the matter
yeah it does look like it was racer
oh so they brought that game over to the
PS4 and switch
what did that happen
yeah I have no idea all right so
let's get on with the show what's going
on you guys this is this is gaming
addict here well lore addict coming at
you if another show we talk about the
past present future game I got I got my
uh co-host with me Dart crickety what's
what's been going on there I saw you had
King on yesterday I was in there yeah
man speak in my speak
yeah man King solo we broke a record
highlight 580 something live
you know King brings numbers so yeah
it was fun it was it was a lot of fun it
was a funny show man it was a funny show
see the uh the thing though is people
might bring people to
to your show but they stay for you
because once that person's left you're
the only thing that remains so you know
I'm glad you said that because I think
that's very important um like we don't
have a lot of guests on because of that
you know because if somebody come to
view a guests
and once that guest leaves will they
come back to my channel so I think the
uh see like the previous record we had
was 561 and that was just like you know
at 561 live and that was just us we
didn't have a guest on that day and I
think that's very important because if
you constantly have a guest on
hey what about us you know so it was
like
we want people to come to our channel
for us
as opposed to you know it's it's cool to
get you know like get a guess on and you
know have some people to come see the
guest but if we suck then they don't
want to come back so so we have to make
sure they think we're entertaining also
see you might have a different show than
IOP but I feel like the humor's still
there no absolutely okay because
sometimes man I I I'd be I would
literally see
the same skits you do in life every time
I see one of those things it's like like
it's just it's just funny man he called
me laughing he's like man they stupid
over there but in a good way
yes yes it was a lot of fun bro it was a
lot of fun
so for those of you in the chat uh you
know there is some things that we're
gonna be talking about today uh we will
be talking about
the Video Game Awards how Microsoft
decided to uh skip that day uh we're
gonna be talking about
apparently Xbox offered Cod on
PlayStation Plus for 10 years on
Playstation uh well yeah offer them to
put it on PlayStation Plus and I see
Xbox gamers
saying they're gonna boycott Final
Fantasy Crisis Core reunion because uh
because they don't put the other ones
that I want to get you know I want to
pick your mind about that and obviously
there might be little things you know
how it is sometimes I'll have like
literally because I don't know if you
guys notice but if you look in the
description that's the topics every day
I have them up before the podcast and I
just literally edit them like live but
sometimes you guys be uh what's wrong
looking for
dirt or a guest
will be like okay okay I got we can make
it a topic right here live
so you know first thing I think I want
to talk about is just exactly you know
what what games you playing and then
yeah because I think I think that's
important I think that's something that
should never leave someone's like days
like because we play games and I feel
like even I get very
like over
I even I'm just like I'm done talking
about games but I feel like
talking about what we're playing is
extremely important yeah
well I recently finished Callisto
protocol which I loved I thought the
game was was a damn good game
um I can't wait for the DLC or whatever
you call it because it did end on a
cliffhanger kinda
um and also I just started high on life
funny as hell hey look man
there's not too many games that made me
laugh laugh out loud like seriously this
one was is so far it's hilarious I love
the adult humor
it's just well done so far I'm truly
enjoying the game
yeah
um I need a I need to jump in there and
try that man because I I've seen like a
little couple videos on it and I haven't
really like jumped it's in Game Pass I
clearly I know that uh right because I'm
sure someone
game is yes I know it's in Game Pass you
don't have to even say that in the chat
and now they'll probably say that in the
chat just because I said not to say it
but anyway so I just I love the humor
the only thing I've seen that I because
I've seen like
gay play a little bit towards the end of
the game and I would love to have the
guns have changed throughout the game
you know what I'm saying like depending
on the decisions you make some like
let's say the first gun you get like he
changes and he talks different in the
end because of the decisions that you
did because it seems like they're there
to comment on the bad things you do but
it never changes them as a person you
know what I'm saying right like I saw
one picture the IG oh one video IGN
posted on Twitter that you can literally
pass these people on a bridge you don't
have to shoot none of them they're
they're neutral characters they won't
shoot you but if you kill them your
gun's like oh so we could finally move
on I'm pretty sure we could have moved
on before you massacred all those people
like yeah and it's finally stuck man the
gun is hilarious it was one part what I
was about to I tried to kill this little
furry animal he was like what are you
crazy you can't kill that little animal
like that and he won't let you freaking
do it either bro it's like it's a funny
game talk about the one that's
teleporting no this one was like a brown
furry little creature that was on the
jungle I saw someone stream and it was
like this thing that was following you
around and it wouldn't let you shoot it
and it was telling you it's life story
it was pulling a Christopher on us man
it was so they're talking the entire
time and then the the first because this
is the very beginning of the game it
looked like and the gun was like does
this thing ever shut up and no matter
where you went this thing followed you
and it was talking the entire time and
all you hear is on what it left the
thing with uh the the uh what's the
first gun's name was someone in the chat
tell me the first gun's name Kenny I
think his name's Kenny and then Kenny
was like thank God it's gone I was so
tired of that like it's a funny game man
like I I saw some people say they hate
the banters too much talking it's
hilarious but they give you the option I
think that's what gives it it's it's
flavor though absolutely but they still
have the option to cut it off if you
want
you can stop the you can stop all the
banter but I love it man it's a funny
game man that damn knife
yo he's crazy bro he'd be talking so
much trash I think it's hilarious
oh I'm sorry yeah I should well I I
guess that was a spoiler but it didn't
really spoil anything drastic it's just
giving you an example of the banter but
I I'll keep that in mind uh only on Xbox
I won't really talk about too much that
and it's only stuff I've been seeing but
I think what I'm gonna do
it's Friday I'm a streamer I'm gonna
stream it like five-ish I try to keep
everything either near IOP time and air
attic show time I try to make sure my
life is rough riding around those two
times next year uh there will be
hopefully some changes I'm thinking
about adding a third person on the panel
but I gotta negotiate with them
because uh it's time frames uh if it
can't work it can't work you know uh
well we'll figure it out I like the
banter between me and uh and dirt but
sometimes you know
it would be nice to have a third person
to bounce off of I don't know yet though
we'll we'll get back to that but let's
go and start the show man
um
so let's talk so right now we're at 17
minutes
in 30 seconds and we're going to talk
about Square Enix
potentially being boycotted by Xbox
Gamers first off Dirk do you believe in
boycotts
um yeah
yeah
I don't know I do believe in them um not
necessarily
I guess it depends on the severity of
the boycott in my opinion
um
but yes I do believe
I personally feel like okay I'm never
gonna tell someone a boycott something
but I will inform people on the reasons
why you would boycott someone
I do believe
that
if
first off I don't know why Xbox gamers
are buying
Final Fantasy VII Crisis Core
reunion because you're not going to get
the games that it represents
that's literally a prequel to Final
Fantasy VII guess what chat
we're not getting the sequels
so that part of me
part of me does feel like if you want to
boycott this game because of that I
understand I totally understand I think
that
because the way Square Enix has been
treating Xbox gamers in general if
you've had enough and you want to just
stop that I I totally understand I
wouldn't hold anything past anyone right
now that's saying look I'm not gonna buy
anything score Enix because of the way
they've been acting on Xbox and to be
honest with you you won't really have
too much of an issue because none of
their games really come to Xbox two
dollars super jump from drawing TJ hi
guys what's up TJ two dollar super chef
from Taz ironically just got an ad for
octopod travel too oh yeah Taz we ain't
getting that game either
and that's why I'm like
if they don't respect the Xbox Gamers
enough to make sure that they get the
game
then I understand people wanting to
boycott them what do you think about
this dirt
yeah I think you made a great point now
me like me personally I'm not into those
games
um but there are plenty of people that
are into those games like like yourself
so that's like just imagine if
the whole Resident Evil franchise was on
the PlayStation
all of the Resident Evil games and the
only one that Xbox got was Resident Evil
3 right
what
that's like man you don't even want to
bother even playing it because you can't
play the other ones on the same platform
and everybody doesn't have a PlayStation
there's a lot of Xbox fans that prefer
Xbox that prefer achievements over
trophies that want to play it on Xbox
this is definitely intentional to just
release this game on Xbox but all of the
others are not on Xbox they don't even
have a date to come to Xbox
there's no plan for those other Final
Fantasy games to to come to Xbox you
know so
I totally understand the boycott it just
seems like this is all deliberate I'm
not sure if it's because Sony has a deal
with PlayStation I'm sorry with uh
Square Enix they clearly have a good
relationship
but this is ridiculous man how could you
just add one game here one game there no
no this is not right
hey you on me bro
my bad I think the biggest issue is the
Unexplained when we see Final Fantasy 7
remake it says at PlayStation exclusive
you can't you can't talk around that we
understand PlayStations are off the back
we understand why it's not coming to the
Xbox platform but when you see some
octopi traveler too there's no X
PlayStation exclusive on that when you
see uh ogre tactics it's on every
platform but Xbox yeah when you see uh
Final Fantasy uh pixels it's on every
Platinum platform but Xbox
those don't make sense because there's
nothing behind that and then people
think but edit
um the reason that that happens is
because it doesn't sell on the Xbox then
why I just sounded like Smooth there for
a second then explain to me why crisis
scores on Xbox
yeah yeah explain to me why you would
put something like
um Final Fantasy strangers of paradise
on Xbox
if they was truly the what's going on
why are none of those games on Xbox and
I I think
my biggest issue with the whole thing is
even if it is dirt even if it's one of
those things where it's like look
the Xbox facility you know it doesn't
sell as well as the other platforms okay
I get that but people be launching stuff
on stadia and that Stadium like look
I talk to people that are in the know
and this is the way they told me about
when it comes to porting stuff they say
addict it doesn't take that long to Port
games something like remake might take
nine months now you think that's a lot
of money
first off
some people export to another company
there's multiple ways they make money
they sometimes they'll make money from a
percentage of the sales of that Port
game or sometimes they'll get a whole
amount that's the way I've been
described now when it comes to this
nine months
is a little long considering how some of
these other games come out and nine
times out of ten when a team ports a
game it's a fraction of the people that
made it
so I was told
most games easily make that money back
by selling it easily make that money
back that cost support it
um it makes no sense why the games out
on Xbox and then people sit there and
say well you know look what octopath
traveler did look what the Final Fantasy
games yeah they came out years after it
came out on the original platform all
right and what's funny is like if we go
through here and we look up triangle
strategy and we look up octopus Traveler
I guarantee you they're not selling
Millions upon Millions upon millions of
copies
their own games ain't selling that well
you know what you know octopi Travelers
start on Playstation dirt
well zero it's not on PlayStation
right it was a Nintendo so why is two
coming on Playstation
um
I even think about that I forget that
wasn't on PlayStation
that was a Nintendo switch game wasn't
it right now it makes absolutely no
sense like zero and then I just get so
annoyed that look
I got a PlayStation okay it's it's right
here
there it is right there
I could play all this stuff
I even considered picking up uh um
Final Fantasy uh reunion just because I
wanted to play it out for IOP Sunday and
I wanted to like really give my opinion
on it because I'm a content creator I
think these rules don't apply to content
creators and let me explain why content
creators
their job is kind of getting in the mush
I'ma be real if you guys like even
though we might have more a more of
something so as a content creator you
have to break it to find out if you was
right about it or not because you can't
really thoroughly give your opinion
correctly if you haven't played the game
um you know I can understand certain
scenarios where content creators don't
do them but if if you are serious about
content creation uh you unfortunately
you have to to cross the picket line
when it comes to stuff like this
yeah
I just would like if if there's some
exclusive dough just come out and say it
like and I feel like I feel like there's
a good chance PlayStations bought Square
Enix like at least have like a handshake
though or something going on or
something on the writing and they're
scared to announce it because What's it
gonna look like if they're on national
TV crying about the the Bethesda
acquisition Bethesda and the the
um the Activision acquisition when
they're over there buying Square Enix
which is a publisher also yeah I
wouldn't be surprised like six months
after that deal is done they formally
announced that they're buying Square
Enix yeah that's what it seems like bro
because it seems so intentional like you
said
you might as well not release any of
those games on Xbox
and why pick and choose right
white Pig and choose certain games to
put on Xbox it almost seems like
PlayStation said um like like screens
and Playstation you know like have some
type of media labels running out of
games Final Fantasy 7 remake nah don't
put that on Xbox
um crisis called yeah yeah you can get
that to them you know it was like Final
Fantasy 16 nope that's us that's so it
just seems like it's intentional man and
um I don't know yeah but you're
absolutely right it makes absolutely no
sense
okay guys I see it doctor see this is
what I'm talking about Dr disrespects
comments
I guess we gotta talk about it because
uh for some reason they care about what
Dr disrespect has
what do you say I do I did see a lot of
people commenting on this so I guess we
can talk about this briefly because
there's not really a whole lot to talk
about when it comes to uh
um when it comes to this whole thing
going on right now uh Square Enix ain't
giving a game there ain't a whole lot
you could do about it I do think that's
it's like I said you guys want to
boycott it boycott it man I need to go
sit here and tell you I probably I'm not
gonna I'm not buying it right now
because I just got so much stuff going
on we do we do have a big Sunday planned
in terms of uh a show so where I I'm
right now I'm focusing on that because
I'm going to be doing a lot of the back
end stuff on that but okay Doctor
disrespect
famous for playing BR games he's famous
for playing PR games uh you know uh I
don't know he used to play fortnite I
don't know fortnite war zone Apex
Legends anything that he could shoot
people with a gun that man is on he came
out and said that
Warzone ain't doing it for him anymore
he wishes there was more to play but
there's nothing and all he wants to do
is have fun uh people was on that boy's
ass man people were like he would play
more than BR you would enjoy yourself
I'm sure there's a lot of um
a lot of PlayStation people saying good
Ragnarok just came out though there's
nothing to play like you know here's the
thing let me explain to you guys
with with him
he's a businessman he's built a brand
he kind of has to play stuff that he can
stream because he streams so much like
this this man will sit down and stream
for like nine hours straight I don't
know how crazy I have no clue how he
does it
after five hours of IOP which uh you
know we used to go from three to four
but occasionally we'll have certain
topics where we're up in the fives I'm
dead like mentally and somehow I'm
physically dead too I don't even know
how that happens I guess maybe sitting
in the chair that long so I don't know
how he does it for nine hours so it's
got to make sense for him to actually
sit down and stream that man plays games
for a living you know we might talk
about game this man is actually playing
the games for Olivia I all day long I'd
rather do a podcast than sit down
playing games 24 7. like and it's not
necessarily because I hate playing games
it's because I feel like with podcasting
you still have that like Center volume
where you can separate your games away
from the actual Talking where you can
actually play the games you can enjoy
them I review games so that takes a
little bit more off that that hurts me a
little bit more but when you review
games or it's worse when you stream
games because you have to play these
games so much that
your livelihood Becomes of what you play
now is this man talking about there's
nothing to play no he's probably playing
something offline but here's the thing
when you play for nine hours straight
dirt do you think he wants to play games
when he gets off
I would think not yeah he's probably
spinning that's a full man's work yeah
that's a full day of work man yeah he's
doing he's not focusing on anything and
I look
there's certain streamers that have been
very successful at it but look at his
perspective gets banned off twitch uh
comes back to Twitch gets banned off
twitch again
on YouTube there's nowhere else for this
man's to go
so he's like look I got to keep my
viewership happy and if you follow a
streamer because of BR games mainly sure
you can probably dip your toes and other
stuff but look YouTube is is ruthless if
you don't make content pretty frequently
on YouTube you are a last week's person
is way different if you don't stream
weekly at least three or four days a
week so that will go to someone else
hmm
what was he gonna say no no no I was
just agreeing with what you were saying
yeah so it's like on my YouTube I'm not
saying that he
he shouldn't play other games and I do
think he should expand his branding a
little bit because if he's if it's
taking that much on his mental state to
play these BR games he should do that
but at the same time
you gotta look from his perspective uh
you know I'm sure that there's content
creators that could vouch for me on this
you'd be doing YouTube and stuff so long
that if you like one week you just don't
feel good like
you just don't do a podcast or don't do
a video you feel like you owe the
audience it even if you feel like [ __ ]
you still feel like man I should do it
though like and imagine that on a bigger
scale because this man streams to
hundreds of thousands of people
well yeah eventually I don't think he
gets that many like viewership live but
he streams to a lot of people uh it's my
sympathies out to these people man look
look they could play other games and
they should play other games but I'm
sure that's stressful to to love gaming
to make it your get your hobby and I
feel that way to a point and I'm sure
you can fill dirt where
I do regret to some degree mixing my
hobby was something I do on the side
because it makes because I feel like I
OD myself on games sometimes and that's
why you know you guys don't see me doing
stuff a lot uh because I'll be like man
I don't want to talk about this like
so hey let me say this addict see the
one thing that I don't think you
mentioned or I don't think people
realize
as a full-time content creator I'm
part-time I have a regular job I've been
in my job for 23 years and I'm going to
retire from this job
YouTube is not my full-time job but when
you make YouTube your full-time job and
you actually
see success from that job a lot of
success a lot of success things are
compromised let me explain
if you built your channel on BR if you
built your channel on talking a lot of
trash if you build your channel on
Hayden PlayStation or hating Xbox or
whatever
when it's your full-time job you have to
keep your audience happy
doctor disrespect might be a casual if
all he plays is be ours yes that's
definitely a casual
but his same audience like the audience
that he built from BR games they might
not want to see him play God of War they
might not want to see him play you know
those other games you know what I'm
saying let me give you a good example of
an individual big streamer that pretty
much everyone in the chat should know
that did what we're talking about trying
to expand his audience and he got
screwed Ninja
ninja got tired of playing fortnite so
much he stopped playing fortnite as much
as he used to and now he's like the top
hundred streamers now not the top 10.
this man was the top 10 streamers for
years got tired of fortnight wanted to
play something else now look where he is
now he's still more wealthier than than
most streamers but
what's funny is he says too that he's
happiest he's ever been uh but you got
to keep in mind you know doctor
disrespect probably got some money money
stacked away but ninja took that YouTube
Red I took the YouTube red ninja took
the Netflix brand not Netflix uh the
mixer bread mixerbread yeah he took all
that bread and you know I think that
that really helps him
when it comes to doing certain things
he's able to do that decision because
he's
he's probably set for life now like
ninja probably won't struggle for
anything ninja probably got paid more
from Microsoft and mixer than some of
these people make their whole life
streaming absolutely so in other words
he can't afford to gamble right he can
afford to take that risk of of losing
his dedicated fans because he he got
that bag for Microsoft you know what I'm
saying they pay them for pretty
magnificent bags I'm pretty sure it was
pretty good so he could take that chance
he could take that risk there are some
people that is don't want to take a risk
like doctor's like Dr disrespect he's
looking for the next BR game he's not
about to go play higher life or no stuff
like that or God of War because his his
already bro it's like I always say
like my audience
um
I'm an Xbox guy I talk trash on Pro Xbox
if I all of a sudden became an Xbox
hater overnight like some people have
done in the past in the community down
here if I all of a sudden became an Xbox
hater overnight you know I was wrong
Xbox is trash PlayStation is the best
thing of all time I cannot expect it's
the price right exactly I cannot expect
the audience that that that came to my
channel because they love Xbox as much
as I do I cannot expect them to support
me the same way they would be like hold
on dirt wait wait wait wait wait a
minute
what the hell are you doing now I could
tell you in the past there were some
channels I loved and they flipped right
and I'm like what are you kidding me I
came to your channel because at that
time you know you hear a lot of Xbox hey
I came you're trying to hear some Xbox
praise now I'm hearing hate on your
channel so no so people don't want to
hear that man no I'm not saying because
someone said he was playing cholesterol
the other day I'm sure he plays other
games from time to time he when he was
on there talking he was talking about I
wish I had another game to play to my my
streamers like to to my audience he was
talking about another huge BR game that
comes out of nowhere that's why he
advocated so much for Gamepad uh for
Xbox to make Halo a um games as a
service uh BR game keep take over real
quick my brother's calling me yeah so
yeah look him playing Callisto protocols
I think that's cool but like attic is
saying his bread and butter is beyond
games bro and people love to watch BR
and as good as Calista protocol is
because I love it
everybody's not into horror games I know
his commentary is hilarious now
disrespect is funny but
nah man he want another VR game so what
I was trying to say and you guys are in
the chat y'all talking trash I love it
you can't just like you can't just turn
on your fan base I I told a story on my
channel I love NBA basketball I'm I was
subbed to a Detroit Pistons Channel
because I'm a Detroit Piston fan and
this guy I was sub to his channel great
channel for weeks he had great Detroit
Piston concert all of a sudden this dude
start talking about anime
and I was like what
why is this guy talking about anime you
are a Detroit Piston child
overnight he didn't start talking about
anime and I remember leaving the comment
like bro this is cool and all but you
should probably start another Channel
instead of the the channel that you
built
talking about NBA basketball all of a
sudden you know we didn't sub to you for
that so the people that subbed to Dr
disrespect they didn't sub to him to
watch him play Pokemon
yeah I'm saying so if he started to play
a Pokemon let's say how long man no so
and but he knows that that's why he
wants that next big br game that's what
he's looking for
it's just like look regardless how you
feel about doctor disrespect and that
whole thing like that whole Community
going through it like uh Destiny I know
a lot of Destiny streamers they're all
worried about the the health and future
of Destiny because once Destiny's gone
they're gone their relevancy is over
right there's a lot of there's a lot of
big channels that did Destiny that's
like um there's one that went to uh Gish
an impact like he just stopped Destiny
entirely and went against an impact and
the reason he did that is because
there's a lot of uh issues that he's
felt with Destiny he didn't know the
future Destiny and he didn't want to sit
on one side of
um
he didn't want to sit on one side
of the of the lake and hope it wouldn't
sink we got a two dollar uh Super Chat
from Mandingo thickens uh Mandingo
mcdickins uh sup attic is that a new uh
dirt IOP hoodie we don't have to do
hoodies what hoodie is that because he's
trying to say is is black man come on
man show some damn respect we're now on
on WBZ we're on attic we're on Lewis
Channel and Alex show man show some
respect damn it it's fine man it's fine
it's it's jokes I'm all about the jokes
man so you know that's pretty much as
far as like we're gonna talk about when
it comes to a doctor disrespect well
it's as funny as I didn't get the super
I didn't get the uh
the
uh the time stamp for that sorry uh time
step oh yeah that's gonna be oh yeah
I apologize I apologize again okay I'm
gonna say 20 minutes I'm gonna say 20. I
say we was talking talking about that
about 15 minutes you think
uh let's say 25 minutes 25 minutes we
were talking because we didn't talk for
Square Enix for a long let's say 20
minutes
we're probably completely wrong on that
I don't know but you always go back and
check no I'm not checking
look
the time stance is really they just say
uh what's the word I'm looking for hey
I'm not going back they're just they
just help you you know what you click on
that time step they might be accurate
okay it might be might maybe maybe not
sometimes they'll be wrong and then you
know I'm a blame I'm gonna blame kid
somebody that they're wrong
40 40 minutes and 30 seconds
all right you know what I want to talk
about actually
what's that I've been seeing
I saw some comments
of 40 minutes 41 minutes and 40 seconds
about Halo
have you have you seen the new stuff
that Halo forge is doing
stuff I saw yeah stuff that people's
been posting absolutely yeah
yeah some of that stuff is incredible
they have remade Almost every map you
can think of I saw Haven from Halo 4.
yeah I saw lockout all kinds of stuff
man and I
look I'm not going to say
that they're they're back on top they're
not uh they still have a long way to go
apparently the spikes has been drastic
spikes on Halo infinite like people on
Steam were playing it like a lot more
crazy now I'm assuming that is going to
happen over to uh Xbox
look yeah if someone said there's a doom
map
so this is why I feel
I feel
this is someone made a rainbow road I
saw that did you see that someone made a
rainbow road you know it's it's it's
crazy man it's I I looked on there and
if you look at Maps there's like 300
pages of maps wow it's it's absolutely
insane and that's what I'm saying like
I'm not saying Halo is back on top with
this because they got a long way to go
they got to
get the they got to get the trust back
of the community and I think that's the
number one goal they've done a decent
amount to inch their way back into that
but
they can't handle story because I have a
feeling Halo infinite what they thought
when it launched in Halo infant what it
is now is two entirely different things
I think that Halo infinite that 10-year
that's done I don't think that that's
that's over right uh they I think
they're gonna go back to the traditional
dropping Halo stuff you know what I'm
saying so but what I would like for them
to do is rename hail infinite to
something else or keep it a little
infinite and keep that just
the playground you go to play the
multiplayer and
every couple years release
uh
a Halo story to add on to what's going
on I think that's what they're gonna do
yeah I was just about to say I could see
them doing that
and
I just look there's a couple things that
they need to do I feel like they need to
look at the forge maps that make the
most sense especially remakes of their
old maps and and just QA the hell out of
it you know really make sure that map
functions exactly are the map supposed
to function
and then hit up the person that made it
be like yo you know what's your PayPal
slide them some bread because obviously
I feel like if you just start snatching
these things and and putting them on um
on the right playlist people feel away
sure they would love it but I feel like
PR wise would probably be better for you
to pay for them and you probably
wouldn't even have to pay them much for
their services like they use your your
tools obviously so it's not like they're
making these and then take that put it
in the rank playlist uh obviously
there's a couple couple maps that they
can do that to there's a guardian have
you seen the guardian map yeah yeah it's
almost one for one
I just want to know how they're doing it
I don't know man some of these maps are
incredible I saw the Mario Kart map did
you see that one
oh the one the old N64 one they're like
it's like a rainbow
um yeah right Rainbow Road that's what
yeah okay yeah that's right that's right
it's just crazy it's it's impressive and
then you really see that in the gaming
community
we got some very impressive people man
couldn't be me but we got some
impressive people I do want to make a
map on there uh I'll probably have to
like
figure out a way maybe make it like a
contest whoever makes the better one
gets like 500 or something I don't know
I'll have to talk to solve you know so
so
got the leash on the money yeah so
sometimes sometimes he lets me rock off
sometimes he doesn't now I probably
wouldn't be able to get 500 he'll
probably say are you out of your mind I
got to make it enough to see but when
people see that amount it encourages
them to do better and better stuff you
know what I'm saying so what I would
like is a Halo infinite map that has
four sections and one represents every
Lord
hmm
and I want like a stat like our statues
I want the statues there's a big statue
in the middle
or somewhere it doesn't have to be in
the middle of every map of every section
of the map and it's got our statues on
it
yeah so I think that would be cool now
I'm not a creative person when it comes
to stuff like that I can make the map
but as far as like making the statue you
can make the statue I've seen people do
some creative stuff on that like some
creative stuff
uh it's just it's interesting man it's
nice to see some form of success come
from the 343 team sure they didn't make
any of these I saw someone make a Peach
castle did you see that Mario Pizza
it's crazy man it's crazy there's a
there's just one map
where it's like it's like one Bridge
the connect the bridge connects two
castles
and then there's like a grappling hook
area under it
to get to the on to every cast to get to
both castles from under it and it's
pretty much like big Team Battle on each
side and it's capture the flag
do you know what I hate
I hate how
uh some of these Fanboys are using Halo
infinite
as a way to bash Xbox like
oh look at handle everything y'all got
pink to Mint and Halo infinite like okay
hello infinite
it's a pretty good game yes the content
didn't drop as frequently as we would
like but the gameplay has always been
solid the campaign was solid the only
issue is yes the content has been
dropping so I hate how these guys are
using Halo infinite as a no no no y'all
the Halo infinite
yeah so I was like I just want three
four three just to shut these people the
hell up just shut them up it would be so
nice you know yeah and you know the
forge
it looks great man um just just you know
more content and like whenever they drop
another campaign which would probably be
what 2024 or something
I can't wait I was ready for three four
three to shut all the haters up
yeah cause people keep saying oh
you know move on to to a point I agree
maybe it's time to do something
different with the uh uh with the Halo
franchise maybe put that down for a
little bit but at the end of the day
it's like
I want to believe 343 can do this like I
truly want to believe that they can
actually take this to the promised land
let me get these super chats uh drawing
TJ being extra I already see this going
down let me make sure I got disconnected
all right so drawn TJ says what do you
uh when do you think we will see the
Halo infinite Battle Royale or get it
next year
TJ there is Mr Clean
so we say in every ball Knows Mr Clean
yeah
he did say just kidding though he did
say just no no hey that's the homie man
you got a 20 super trap from ko3 black
truth what's good fam working 12 hours
today already listening to a six hour
uh a six hour podcast from IOP that then
two hours of wbg with King so it's only
right eye in the day with the attic show
appreciate it man you need to watch that
you need to watch that r r that me and
King did yesterday too we we ranked all
of the phase four projects the movies
and the TV shows we ranked them all
towards number one I ain't get a chance
to watch it Marvel uh Superman it's not
not Superman Spider-Man I agree with
that yeah what's funny is I already
because it was like it wasn't ranked it
was like s a b c d rankings and we were
fighting
for what was in the A and there was only
one other game one other project in a
and that was that was Loki and he didn't
want to put it nay because he said I
personally feel like I know an S he said
he doesn't want to put on the same tier
Spider-Man because he feels like it's an
a I was like I feel you I was like but
without Loki storyline Spider-Man
doesn't happen
because Loki is the one that opened up
the Pandora's Box known as the
Multiverse yeah that's right and it's
just like look it would be different if
Loki was a bad show but it was a great
show and on top of that Loki was the
Catalyst that led to all the movies
true true
any match it is what was your worst
rated show Thor
Thor or black widow one of those two
right I thought Black Widow would have
been good if it would have came out
during the time that the timeline that
the movie was actually you know the time
of the movie yeah so I
you know what I was going to tell you
the the linking listings but if people
people might want to actually like see
it live so that's fine it's just you
know when it comes to forge I honestly
feel like they got something man they
really got something and I feel like
they need to take this they need to fix
the Cosmetic System they need to have
grifball why isn't Griff ball back yet
like it's it's crazy that Griff Ball's
not even there infection not there
just do some fun stuff man do some fun
stuff build that rank listing and get
some good cosmetics in there you can get
through the season pass and they'll be
fine but it just like one of the things
that you look at fortnite and you look
at like the battle pass
there's so much good stuff in that
battle pass that use like yo I want the
geralts in there you got um uh some cool
looking night thing you got a lot of
cool stuff to Doom Slayers in there
like the dude the main character from
Doom you could see okay this is worth
ten dollars eleven dollars twelve
dollars you look at let's be real you
look at the three four threes battle
pass for Halo infinite it's just like
it's just changed it up so like a pet
like instead of a beat Circle it's half
a square in circle like it's just
there's nothing there that is so lit
that you want it I think the closest
thing they had was making you look like
reach characters
that was cool but that was it like I
can't really I think they had some like
flaming skull stuff they need to
capitalize more on that like oh do this
one you know you get the flaming skull
one or you or do this one you'll get the
blue flaming skull one like little stuff
like that would go a long way but it it
definitely feels like that's one of the
key things that monetization system they
need to fix that over a lot of things to
be honest with you yeah because if
they're going to get into a Groove
eventually yeah
if there's one thing that we were
complain about heavy
we will complain about a bad poorly
implemented monetization system if
you're making me pay for little stuff
like colors they were making you pay for
basic colors colors that you were
painting in art class in the third grade
should never do that man
because you can't really
you can't be
you can't what's what I'm looking for
uh you can't be creative on how your
Spartan looks by locking colors behind a
paywall
it just it doesn't work that way man but
anyway
let's get to some of the juicy stuff man
all right let's get to some of the juicy
stuff we are 53 minutes we'll just say
54 minutes we're getting into Xbox and
Call of Duty though I'm I'm tired of
talking about this let me point this out
there
I'm tired of talking about this but
unfortunately
every time something happens it's it's
big enough where I feel like we have to
talk about it and Xbox giving
was what I'm looking for
giving a PlayStation the ability to put
Call of Duty in PlayStation Plus do you
think that's big enough to talk about
dirt
yeah you damn right it is do you think
that they if this is true because I
don't think they ever confirmed it
obviously but man doesn't that kind of
like
contradict the whole point of them
getting it because if they're just
allowing them to put it on on
PlayStation Plus then that takes the
whole purpose away
that takes a huge Advantage away
um it just seems like this to me man I
gotta be honest um I was kind of like
I understand leaving Call of Duty on
Playstation because it is a huge
franchise and they might not be able to
get the deal done without
leaving it in on Playstation okay fine
but the rumor that they offered it to be
in PlayStation Plus I'm like hold on man
what the hell I was kind of like no no
no no that's a little bit too much
you're giving up a little bit too much
there because
it makes it seem like to me I know this
is a business thing and of course the
Activision Blizzard acquisition is about
More Than Just Call of Duty
but it seems like to me if they did that
is like yo
PlayStation just
damn
like all of the things that PlayStation
has done to Xbox in the past
and Xbox had to take it
some of the wounds were self-inflicted
but Xbox had to take it PlayStation you
know did some crazy things in 2013
they've you know taken exclusives away
and all this crazy stuff and it's like
for them to offer that like I said I
understand it because they're really
trying to get the deal done and it's
more than just Call of Duty but damn bro
I was kind of like irritated like come
on now y'all offering to put it in their
service
what
so yeah I didn't I didn't like it um
I don't know what's going to happen with
this whole thing it started to be
annoying
this whole thing is starting to be
annoying you know there was some more
stuff said by Brad Smith today
how the FTC
he pretty much said the FTC didn't even
want to talk
they they didn't want to sit down and
even talk to Xbox let Xbox even State
their case or negotiate or anything they
didn't really talk
as much as I don't like conspiracy
theories I got it feels like something
more is going on here like me either
Microsoft's being targeted or I kind of
feel like
I know this is going to sound crazy Chad
I know it's gonna sound crazy but it
does feel like you know maybe
PlayStation went over there they greased
the wrong the right hands does it not
feel like that like to not even want to
talk to them like not even don't talk to
them I don't know much it's like I said
you guys got to refer to Hogue I think
hoes under the weather right now so he
hasn't really made a video about what's
going on today but it's just like
to not even want to talk to them I just
it feels like
it does feel like they have no interest
in whatever they say because you would
not the only reason that you would not
talk to someone like refuse to talk to
someone is if you know without shadow of
a doubt whatever they say you're not
going to care about and to me the only
way that makes sense is if they can't
agree with whatever they say
um
it's it's crazy bro it's crazy like you
said
just not to even want to talk to them
like no we don't want to hear nothing
y'all got to say okay well we're trying
to please you guys in every way we can
to get this deal done we're leaving this
game that PlayStation is the only the
only
people that's against this acquisition
nobody else
but there was even a statement from
another company that was redacted so we
don't know exactly who it was but they
have no problem with this acquisition
another big gaming company
PlayStation is literally the only ones
that's against this
super chat's too much I don't even see
it
five dollars from Corey Tidwell PS can't
afford it we are talking about a 250 a
million a month for a month is that do
they is that what the numbers were they
would charge them 250 million a month to
put Call of Duty on Game Pass it was
that just speculation I haven't
memorized numbers and they've got a two
dollar super Chef for Mandingo big
Dickens they agree something though
right
and it wasn't hands it says Mandingo man
that's how you get down man he funny
dude
uh man but yeah so it it's at the point
not adding I'm just like
disgusted by certain things
PlayStation this I
it's at the point you know Brad Smith
and everybody have to keep on
reiterating you know PlayStation has 70
in the market won't even have 30. and
even though no Xbox guy will sit up here
and say Xbox is winning or beating
PlayStation because they're not
no they're not they haven't since 2013.
um so Xbox themselves like we just don't
understand this PlayStation is winning
70 to 30. why is Xbox getting so much
resistance on this deal is it because
it's Microsoft but back to what I said
only PlayStation is the ones that's
trying to stop this deal
so as far as gaming companies and it's
ridiculous
these people five dollar cigarettes from
Tris you know what it is I think that's
I can't see it at all Jim Ryan must uh
General uh must on his knees giving up
that bomb that you see you saying Jim
Wright giving that glunk a glunk is that
what you're saying a Glock three
thousands oh wow you guys are ridiculous
man I like it I like it it's funny
here's my question to you
do you think that Microsoft is offering
them stuff knowing that they're not
going to accept it knowing that they're
not going to talk to them just so they
can Bond just so they can decapitate
them from the knees at the uh so they so
they could decapitate them from the
knees at um when they sue them when
they're in court like look we offered
them this we offer them that they said
no uh here is a transitions of them not
even returning emails we've done
everything in our power to make this
transition go smoother it's them the
ones that don't want to work with this
we did the exact same thing the
PlayStation and Sony it's them that want
to work with this like do you think that
might be going on absolutely see because
I believe Xbox knows that PlayStation is
just that arrogant to say nope to all of
their offers no we don't want 10 years
of college no we don't want that we
don't know we don't want to put in the
PlayStation Plus
and Xbox is going to say well well
we offered it they didn't want it so
yeah you're right about that man they I
think Xbox knows
they are Microsoft they have the best
lawyers the money can buy I'm sure
they're they know some of the stuff they
predicted some of the stuff ahead of
time that's going to happen but this is
just ridiculous at this point man
it's ridiculous I agree with you
um it would be funny if they do end up
going to court
and they went in court and they get
Activision with no uh no compromises
nothing they do whatever they want with
it and it's like King said PlayStation
should have just took the 10-year deal
because not only after that
because Xbox I do think even if they won
with no restrictions they're still gonna
work with a PlayStation to keep caught
on uh but imagine like like King said
you could they play Xbox like we need we
need yearly updates on what costs sold
on your platform like we need yearly
updates on why you think they're gonna
be like at a job interview where do you
see yourself for 10 years with the car
right
yeah I don't know man you know this is
that's crazy like starting January of
2022 all hell broke loose place I mean
Xbox is buying that division blizzard
throughout this year it was kind of
quiet until the last couple of months
man this stuff is crazy bro there's more
and more stuff is coming out about their
conversations things that happen and I
don't know what to say anymore man I
just don't know what to say anymore
can we
agree
the Jim Ryan's a genius
like just think about it
like Jim Ryan
has made statements in the past that you
could argue
Domino affected
potentially Microsoft losing a 69
billion dollar acquisition hmm
and
that's crazy
all that power on one man
if it yeah if that happens bro it will
be
um
I don't know man you know it's it's kind
of weird because the industry is paying
attention to this and like I and like we
both said the industry is agreeing with
the deal except for Sony activism
blizzard themselves really want this
deal to go through they really want this
deal to go through because then they
approached Microsoft in the first place
um
so they want the deal to go through
obviously and it's like
I know I know they will still make games
for PlayStation because they make money
off of PlayStation but it seemed like
this if this deal didn't go through
it will rub a lot of people the wrong
way in the industry
the problem is
is a lot of people aren't really
invested in anything the people that do
this FTC you know that's true they're
not investing in the gaming Market uh
they don't care about it and it's easier
for people to manipulate people when
they don't care about the brand we got a
five dollar super track from gamer by
choice ain't heard that name in a while
what's going on man uh Microsoft
offering called into PlayStation Plus
was smart because they probably knew
Sony FTC would not accept and now they
have to explain why what deal they
looking for he's got a point there man
you gotta yeah 12 month uh 12 month
member chat from Rel Jim Ryan ran out of
knee pads and throws
these people man that you could have
could have catch it with the knee pass
we gotta go with the throat spray too
oh my God five dollar super strap for
the angry they are pissed what's going
on my dude Microsoft better take the
gloves off and body Jim and Sony all
right see here's the thing though when
you're in a position that Microsoft's in
anything they say can and will be used
them in the court a lot yeah it will
yeah that that's why I honestly feel
like
they've been very quiet with Game Pass
they haven't really if you notice
besides the uh besides
uh the show they didn't really do much
in game pass this year at all
at all uh and it's interesting we got a
couple things at it yeah but it wasn't
to the degree I mean we had outriders
one year octopi traveler come day and
date to the platform they did like
persona but that's really about it like
you might have had to play Still yeah
Flagstaff I'll give you that but my
point is is like every year it seems
like they ante up more and more from the
previous year when it comes to Game Pass
but this year is the first year I felt
like they didn't really take a whole lot
of risks like remember we thought Gotham
nice is going to be there and of naming
all these ridiculous games that would
never be on there and Microsoft was like
I can't imagine what it'd be like to be
Microsoft and like Aaron Greenberg and
Phil Spencer reading like if I've worked
at a company like that being in charge
of like the e3s I would go watch the
Xbox prediction shows just to laugh
because I I remember I had it was
someone from Xbox on IOP and I asked
them
what do they think when they see leaks
you know and and I asked them that and I
said
what is your thought process when you
see leaks that are so hot laying [ __ ]
can never be true and the worst part is
like a lot of the time Microsoft won't
even deny them
they they just they act like oh yeah
we're good we're good and then when
those games aren't announced people get
disappointed it is what it is it's it's
it's interesting man it's interesting
and I think the biggest thing that we
gotta look at here and keep and tell me
if I'm wrong Dirk
is we got to do a better job
at keeping our own expectations in check
uh because I do feel like around E3 I'm
I'm I'm to I'm guilty as well with
everyone uh I want it all
and people sit there like attic your
expectations are they're not right no my
expectations exactly what I want I don't
know about you guys this is what I want
and I want everything
uh and then you know I get disappointed
when I don't get everything
so it's interesting uh you know that
happens yeah that happens though let's
go ahead and move on to uh our final
topic because I'm sure that's going to
be like a 20-minute topic we're at vgas
man uh all right hold on I got a fit I I
still I kind of feel bad a little bit
about the um
about the
the time stamps for the doctor uh for
the doctor disrespect one but all you
gotta do is just go back no I'm good
no it'll be easy it'll be easy you know
why because you have the timestamp for
what's after Dr disrespect so that's
fine so all you got to do is kind of you
know fine right that means I have a
bottle that means I had to listen to The
Show for a good 20 minutes no no no just
fast forward it look man when you click
29 minutes and if we if it doesn't sound
like we're at the beginning of the
doctor first off I am not technically
wrong
okay that 29 minutes is in the doctor
disrespect
time slot I just don't know when it is
you could be listening for five minutes
and then we stop you could be listening
for 10 minutes and we stop you know
what's even worse if that score Enix
topic was longer than I thought and I
click you straight into the score in
this conversation
all right so let's get let's get it
let's get in the Video Game Awards all
right um how did you first off besides
the Xbox stuff because clearly we're
gonna talk about the Xbox stuff how did
you feel about the overall presentation
the pacing uh the game and well maybe
not so much the game announcements
because those can be subjective I'm
trying to like rate the show in general
how did you feel about the show in
general
I thought it was um
I thought it was okay
I you know because I watched it back I
watched uh our stream back it was okay
there was some decent announcements um
for some reason I thought previous years
was better
it was okay
um you know that game Judas looks great
I was a huge fan of BioShock
um
you know there were some other games
that caught my interest the only issue I
would say there were a lot of like
Medieval Time games for whatever reason
don't don't know why but I guess that's
just the just the period of of uh that
these companies want to do games based
in so I thought it was okay I also feel
like Christopher Judge just got the show
off to a bad start
yeah he's part of the shop to a bad
start part of me is like let the man
speak but after you go back and watch it
you clearly see man man they were
telling you to get off the stage they
were straight up telling you your time
is done right and you know what's funny
he tweeted that he wasn't finished did
you see that yeah you know what's what's
funny is um I was looking at the when
when I was watching it
I was unaware that they played music to
rush people off the stage so really he's
sitting there talking and that music
starts playing I'm like oh they they
about him being on stage they're playing
music to hyphen his thought like his
speech I thought like they put him up
there and they were playing that music
because it was like you know I was
trying to make it like an emotional
moment the music's playing and then
people's like no attic they tell him to
get off the stage like yeah that's right
you know what's funny that man gave zero
zero shits about that music he was
talking hearing the music and he was
funny he even made a joke on stage he's
like I hope they don't have a time limit
for speeches like
it's like it's like he knew what he was
doing that man knew what he was doing
like yeah he did he knew he was not
supposed to be up there that long but
here's the thing though
that's what I like sure could have been
better I felt like he could he should
have respected the people their time but
I would have preferred to see him up
there than some advertisement or Jeff
Keeley announcing something like I felt
like
I that's what that's what I'm about I'm
about people getting emotional from the
journeys they made making that mute that
game sure it went too long and it
probably cost Jeff probably an extra ten
thousand dollars in scene steam deck
things but at the end of the day I was
cool with it I honestly say I was cool
with it so besides that you know what
else
well I uh I disagree with you on that
one he was talking too long
so I'm trying to think uh what else I
thought armor core was a pretty good
announcement
um you know I thought death standing too
was a surprise announcement I wasn't
expecting something I wasn't expecting
that either yeah because I didn't think
that game did that well for Sony I
didn't think they were you know gonna do
a sequel but it was also a I don't give
a damn enough because I hated the first
one yeah and I'm not going to even buy
this one at all
um so that was a surprise but that's
that's about it there was a you know
Xbox not being there that's something we
can definitely talk about though yeah
we're going to get to that uh so one out
of ten man what's that what's that video
game and where it's getting
um
you sound like a strong seven you
sounded like I'll give it a I'll give it
a seven maybe six point five yeah
I'm actually I'm giving an eight
I I actually felt like it was well paced
the announcements was there
um you know they took the criticism let
people speak they even let Chris take up
half the the time slot of everyone
speaking
um I it was a huge improvement over last
year to me I felt like the
advertisements was there but they didn't
feel obtrusive you know what I'm saying
uh and obviously people say don't do
don't do the advertisement side he
should do how is it supposed to make
money people sit there look I would
prefer him do the advertisements in that
way where it's it's stuff that's
relevant to that then do average the not
do advertisements we never get another
video game awards because if the if the
event doesn't make money he's never
doing it again
yeah this is literally his his job is
the Video Game Awards the summer game
Fest that's what he does for a living if
he can't make the money to pay for him
the salary of everyone that works for
him the people that he gets to come in
on like temp staffs and stuff to run the
stage then there's nothing there there's
no more Video Game Awards what do you
still think of the Bill Clinton kid look
I don't even know how that dude got on
the stage like that obviously he stuck
up on
um
he got through security at the door
Security on the stage and security at
the stage
Jeff
and you know Carl made a good point
that could have went a completely
different way than it did if anything we
got lucky the outcome of that because
the kid was going up there to make some
kind of lame ass joke it could have went
completely a different way so if
anything that shows Jeff look work on
your security fam like right you
literally had the most influential most
important people in the entire industry
in one place work on your security
so yeah it's like I said eight out of
ten thought it was a good show uh you
know obviously though there was
something about the show and I think I
think everyone noticed it it was it
wasn't as green as it usually is there
was no green there at all yeah besides
some besides some Game Pass commercials
you know that made it worse you won't
show your games but you'll show Game
Pass commercial well I think that made
it worse so tell me your overall
opinions on this dirt like I I I want to
know what Dirk Gregory feels that Xbox
was not at the game awards
it was a letdown but it's always a butt
they um somebody
we were I guess we expected more because
the last few years they were there you
know like last year they showed some
gameplay for hellblade
20 20 they show Perfect Dark
2019 of course with the Xbox series X
and hillblade too
so yeah I um I did want them to show
something I expected them to maybe show
something
related to games they already announced
so you know I was a little disappointed
about that but I got over it
um you know they're not but not thought
about it you know I'm a bot so I said
you know what yes I wanted them to be
there but
they was there every other show this
year they had an E3 they had a Gamescom
it was even that Tokyo game show so them
not having something that uh the game
was it you know I was disappointed but
I got over and now you go ahead do you
do you think that
as Gamers we get entitled to companies
being at almost every event throughout
the year
that's exactly what I'm saying at first
I was disappointment I wasn't mad I was
disappointed like damn Xbox one ain't
show up but then I said hold on man they
they was at E3 they actually had an E3
show they had they was at Gamescom they
actually had a pretty decent Tokyo game
show uh show
and I said okay you know they just
didn't show up because somebody they use
somebody on Twitter used an analogy that
I love they said Xbox not being at the
game awards and people being mad about
it is like
Budweiser not having a commercial at the
Super Bowl and I said
okay that's that's a pretty good analogy
um but like do I think some people
overreacted yeah I do
but that's their opinion they're
entitled to feel how they want to feel
but I didn't say this I go back to this
2023 is going to be a big year for Xbox
Us Xbox fans we've been waiting
we've been anticipating on Xbox it's
time you know 2022 was supposed to be
that year but it didn't happen obviously
they delayed some games we're ready
and I say this to everybody
with the exception of 2021 with Halo
um
for so we had cycle knots
this generation so far
is still a continuation of last
generation
we always say out of y'all Xbox really
didn't have many games in development
besides Halo gears Enforcer
and they had to build some of these
games their building Studios they're
buying Studios they're trying to get
games out and it's unfortunate that
we're waiting so long because not only
like you mentioned this I think last
week or way before last the first batch
of Studios they bought already had
multiplies they will developing
multi-plats right
um the initiative was brand new you know
and that's all brand new
I'm sorry not brand new doing the
multiplayer double fine doing the
multiplex so we had these companies that
they bought we always was doing
Multiplex now they're doing exclusives
but it's a waiting game and covet didn't
help either so it's like damn you know
it's Xbox fans we're like come on guys
we're ready and hopefully 2023 is that
year but as far as the game awards I was
you know I was upset at first I was
disappointed at first but I got over it
and I just said look man
hopefully they can give us some
information early next year about the
games that's releasing next year and
we'll see because they said that these
games are supposed to drop between
at E3 they said from June bless you June
to June they said 12 months so these
games are supposed to drop
we'll see what happened
I think
it's okay to be disappointed if they
wasn't there
um you know and I think it's mainly
about expectations that they set up
always being there
yeah I do feel like they should have
been there at some degree now I got a
little conspiracy theory I need to buy a
tin foil like a prop to put it on my
head that's what I need to do but this
is how I think happened I think that
Microsoft
has so much they need to announce
because they didn't announce release
dates at E3
and they can't just release a release
date like they gotta have probably a new
trailer something to go with the release
date oh you got Forza you got
um Starfield and you also have bright
fall so you got these three games that
probably some Game Pass announcements
you got a lot of stuff you have to work
with this is my assumption
that
probably all that couldn't be at the
Video Game Awards you know that's a lot
of content to be put there and the
show's already long enough
and even if it can do you want to drop
all of your stuff at one event that's
not even yours right
right so this is my thought process
maybe they went to to
Jeff Keeley and maybe he was like look I
can't take all of that it's just it's
not possible uh just speculation maybe
they didn't go to them they just thought
that you know we're not dropping one
thing we got to do our own thing and I
think that they were like look let's
what we're going to do is we're gonna
have our own event because if we give
the Video Game Awards
Starfield redfall or Forza
then we're doing a disservice to
ourselves because if we have to have our
own event why didn't we just hold that
back to make our get better absolutely
so that's what I think happened I think
they had too much to show and they
didn't want to share anything because
they have a show coming in a couple
months maybe an inside Xbox something I
don't know so I think that's the reason
you see nothing big there but I will say
they always have games working on games
as a service Halo
um uh what's the Fallout 76 sea thieves
Elder Scrolls Online they have plenty of
games as a service that could have
appeared at this event
uh yeah sure would we have would we have
liked that no we would have wanted
something different but here's the thing
if you show the new sea thieves
expansion or you show the new
fall at 76 expansion could be three or
four months away but you showed it there
I think that would have kept people
entertained sure they would have been
upset you know hey this is what we would
have heard you know Xbox is there that
only showed seed thieves you know they
got all these games but I know they're
going to show those games I don't think
you would see this much in rangement
because they're not there at all
because and then at the end of
neither at the beginning
or at the after the show Aaron Grandpa
should drop that tweet February the 15th
we're having an Xbox inside diving
deeper into CT not CTS
diving deeper into redfall diving deeper
into fours and Diving deeper into uh
star field I think with those two
combinations you could have probably not
even show nothing at the Video Game
Awards just announcing the date would
have been enough to keep people off your
back that would have yeah that would
have been enough I'm gonna say Okay cool
so we wouldn't have expected anything at
the but I do think they should have
showed something you know showed one of
the expansions they should have did
something and I I I stand by that
because the reason and this is a little
bit on Jeff Keeley too it's like
the Video Game Awards is supposed to be
a culmination of everyone and the fact
that he couldn't get Xbox to come on
their stage
makes me feel like the show suffered
because of it
it is what it is but at the end of the
day we got we gotta do a better job
and not feeling entitled that we are
entitled to Xbox being at that show
that's not their show
they're entire they it's optional for
them to be at that show and I'm not
saying that you can't be disappointed
because I think we're all a little
disappointed but at the same time
it's like it's like Dart said they were
damn near at every event this year at
every event and I do think that you
should have been at this event but who
am I to tell them what to do with their
own IPS now as long as they have an
event like an inside Xbox or something
or maybe like an XO
showing off smaller titles showing off
uh we would be lit if you had like
February you had an Excel format and
then June you had their big E3 yeah I
think that would be cool uh because
there's not a lot of stuff going on in
those beginning months when it comes to
events I don't think it will be an Excel
format I think it might be an inside
Xbox just specializing on those games or
maybe just star field and they'll have
another one I don't know that's I would
like an inside Xbox if they did a
formation like state of play or or the
Nintendo directs if they kind of change
it to like a little 20-minute show with
some updates of big games I I would like
that you know I'm not saying I wasn't
going to do everything like Sony and
Nintendo but I kind of would like that
from them instead of having one big show
a year you know I still like the one big
show but maybe on just to get some
information about some upcoming games
nice little 20 minute you know
slice or whatever you call it and that's
that's my personal opinion on the matter
I got a 10 super trap from dollar to
talk he always
in the 2023 Game Pass commercial there
was a there was new footage for
Starfield and other games plus the new
Xbox Video Production Studio I'm sure
they have already shown they already
have a show early next year and I feel
you on that but here's the thing Don I
think the reason that they should have
announced it is because that's not the
norm and when you do something that's
not the norm you have to assume that
your customers aren't going to expect it
and gonna assume you're not gonna do
anything
that's my biggest thing I just I really
wanted them to be there uh you know
maybe it's because I told you a couple
weeks ago they weren't going to be there
so maybe it's because I already mentally
took them out of the equation
if you notice when we talked about the
Video Game Awards I didn't bring up Xbox
at all
so it is what it is I hope I hope
they're there next year and you know it
could be even worse than this it could
be there's some beef between Jeff Keeley
and Xbox and we don't know about it
maybe something happened and Michael was
there though yeah it was they had a good
point there but I feel like it'd be
weird if Phil wasn't there like we do
this console stuff but at the end of the
day the Video Game Awards isn't supposed
to represent a certain console it's
supposed to represent the industry the
industry right and people are like why
did Phil go there and he didn't have no
games there he wasn't showing games
there I feel bad for the man for having
to sit through all that God Awards
nominated God of War One it seemed like
death strandy too and all that but all
that aside it would be weird if if Phil
Spencer wasn't there that is the video
game award it's like you know it is what
it is I just hope
I I hope dirt
I hope next year
Microsoft is so there and I'm not
talking about game play now it's Mr I
want them to be there with nominations
yes yes and you know what Phil being
there feel
excuse me Phil being there every single
year
he sees these games getting nominated I
know last year they had Psychonauts twos
nominated
but
Phil wants their games up there I really
feel that man who wouldn't as the head
of a of a company of a division in the
company has to say you want your games
to be
to be praised you want your team games
to be praised like yo yo this is the
game of the year I think they would
definitely be there next year at least
nominated
you know because we know like a game
like Starfield is going to be pretty big
and as far as Bethesda just being able
to polish the game a little bit more I
think that's only going to help the game
and us as Xbox fans we want this we get
tired of these other people talking
trash every year oh look oh God the
world got another Ward
I was tired of it and you know how we
feel about it I can't imagine how they
feel about it like it must be a thousand
times worse for them because it's like
look
let's be Microsoft and Playstation they
might talk all nice and stuff but they
there's definitely competition there and
I know yeah without a doubt without a
shred of a doubt Phil Spencer looks at
all these games getting uh put on
nomination lists and sees little to none
of his own game gets up there that man
feeling what and that's why I'm hoping
that that just opens up like a really
what's wrong I'm looking for it's gonna
get him so riled up that he's gonna be
like you know what
that's it it's over and that's what I
hope happens man I think he's I think
that's the point that he's already at uh
addict it says the games you know the
quality games are taking time I think
he's already there and and I think a
year like 2019 when Xbox literally stole
the show
announcing the Xbox series X uh actually
showing the physical console announcing
hellblade too that stole the show that's
the only thing people was talking about
in 2019. who won the game of the year in
2019 I don't even remember
I don't remember either
uh 19.
um I don't remember
so this year was
okay this year was um Elder ring Eldon
ring last year was part two it takes two
2020 was like the year before that was
last it was part two
so that means 19 with six
twice yeah Shakira yeah thank you so but
nobody was talking about that everybody
was talking about Xbox series X and
hellblade too
that's what we're waiting for that Xbox
that stole the show and you know I
believe it's going to be there it's
going to happen again it's just that you
know it's just a waiting game with us
but those days are almost over guys like
my boy Joey in the chat you know Joey
you know we talk about it on a personal
level
yeah we're just ready bro we're ready
I want I'm ready for Xbox just to shut
these people up I'm ready for this
Activision disability deal to be over
with
I'm ready for Xbox to buy more Studios
and create more games and we're ready
bro this time imagine
if next year they got like two games and
games a year Contender I like that'll be
fighting I think that's the biggest
thing you know they they want to see
they want to go up there with numbers
and I get it people have every right to
be like frustrated every right to to
want to see new stuff but at the end of
the day it is better
to take our time it is better to make
sure that when they do get these games
out that these games have quality and I
think I think if as long as the game's
pan out the weight was worth it it's
just absolutely the game's got to pan
out but anyway hey Adam say one more
quick thing don't I think people are
sleeping on red fog but Arcane makes
quality remember definitely was in Game
of the Year running last year Arcane
makes quality games don't sleep on
Arcane bro even though death flute might
not have been for everybody
I loved it after like a couple hours I
loved it because at first I was like
what the hell is going on with this game
but I figured out and I loved it don't
sleep on them
I just wanted to say that buddy yeah I
think that um
I think you guys gonna be very surprised
hopefully we'll lead to good games but
anyway that's the show guys I appreciate
it for coming through you know we have
331 people in the chat hit that like
button let's get that over hit that like
button at the end of the park you're
like button
well you know let me do the the time
stance we got 132 man I
I I do appreciate you know all you guys
for showing up now keep in mind this is
the last podcast for the year uh we are
taking a little bit of a break
and uh you know we deserve it man we we
do this we do this all year long pretty
much and I'll probably still be
streaming but as far as like podcasting
IOP next next iops the last IOP and the
next R R's last r r and then we'll be
back
probably the beginning of next year uh
so you know I get it it's not that big
happens I might do something by myself
maybe as dirt if he wants to jump in but
you know as of right now
this one is the last one for the rest of
the year and then next year we're going
to be energized I'm gonna have that
energy bunny I'm like
and we'll be good man but I appreciate
for coming through and until next time
this is gaming addict Dirk griggity and
what do you got going on greedy
nothing much man
um it's so close to the holiday season I
want to do some content but I haven't
had a topic that I'm feeling I'm tired
of talking about the FTC stuff so I'm I
might not even have I don't know I'm
gonna think of something to do but yeah
man so uh check out the latest episode
of wbg Xbox podcast King Dave was on and
we had a hell of a time man hell of a
time
um so you know I gotta spam the chat
this attic always say you spend the chat
with my uh my channel so check it out
PlayStation Fanboys will not like it I
love to say that
he's like at least he's keeping your
expectations in check I'm gonna let
y'all know because that one guy had uh
well it was like a few weeks ago like
maybe a month ago this I'm like the guy
was a PlayStation Fanboy he was talking
trash in this chat
then I said bro you don't want to come
on my channel talking that trash and you
know I can't think of his name but he
had came over there and I think about
Eric something wasn't it Eric Eric the
beer that was his name Eric the beard
and as soon as he came over there
talking to trash my mom was like who the
f are you I have a weekly I haven't even
seen him in the chat yeah yeah like he
was over here just that one day I guess
huh and but in my Minds they'll play
that mess over there we got some my my
mods are Bots
they've been all five of Chris Hart's uh
accounts they don't want to hear that
crap a couple of them in here man
Jacob J only on Xbox uh it's a few
months that's in here bro yeah so shout
out to you guys man shout out to you we
do share uh the same community in a lot
of ways but appreciate if you guys
coming through
what about Fable talk what if something
happened on Fable I didn't see nothing
yeah something they're arguing about the
the engine
forever like it's this isn't new
slowly because the engine yeah the
conversation's not new that's been out
maybe I knew I don't know sometimes I
get confused on stuff that I know in the
public shows
um Fable is gonna take a little bit 2024
2025. that's all I gotta tell you guys
but I appreciate it hey you guys have a
good day